in 1854 cholera struck the City of
London over 600 people died in just a
few weeks physician John Snow is often
credited with discovering that cholera
is waterborne disease and with ending
the 1854 epidemic by removing the handle
from the contaminated Broad Street pump
the full story is much more interesting
so I've been reading about the Jon Snow
pub for years there it is look at that
right here what used to be Broad Street
is this fine looking Club there's this
very inauspicious sign that says here
the red granite curbstone over there
marks the site of the historic Broad
Street pump associated with dr. Jon
Snow's discovery in 1854 that cholera is
conveyed by water so that's a really
simple summary of the whole Jon Snow
story and to give you just an overview
here's the story so it's 1854 it's
really hot in the end of the summer in
London we're here in Soho which was a
very crowded neighborhood fill of
tenements with people not of a lot of
means and there are a lot of people
crammed into these buildings you know
many many people to an apartment it's
hot and it's sweaty and the part that
you can't imagine
looking right now this is still still
pretty crowded it's not that hot we're
still pretty crowded here the street now
is completely clean we see street
sweeping these vehicles we see drain
into the streets we have sewers none of
that was true in 1854 instead the people
who lived in these buildings some of
them had cesspools in these little front
courtyards and they would take their
human waste and other waste and just
kind of throw it out the window into the
cesspool or bring it down to the
cesspool and then it would drain
wherever it drained and the street well
it was not something that you could
easily walk on and keep your feet clean
wow that's slippery and disgusting and
so people were used to this kind of
somewhat disgusting ambiance and people
thought that when there were terrible
outbreaks of disease especially cholera
that it was caused by the very poisonous
air this miasma that they called it and
the smell from all the poo and all the
animal waste was pretty horrible and it
was a pretty sensible theory to think
that that could be causing disease but
Jon Snow who lives not far from here
will go there later was a physician in
London who was convinced that cholera in
particular was a waterborne disease it
was not carried in this smelly air and
what happened here on this spot in 1854
was that there was baby who lived at
number forty Broad Street which would
have been just about here maybe Louis
who came down with some sort of terrible
disease that caused really terrible
diarrhea and I think pretty quickly
people realize that it was cholera and
that there was going to be another
outbreak of this very terrible disease
people started dying alright so what
happens what happened was the weeks from
baby Lewis and other people who became
ill with the cholera so human fecal
matter mixed with the water supply died
was in a relatively shallow well moving
about 20 feet down under the street
right here and the the cholera bacteria
began to multiply and people would
ingest the water which provides the
human intestine to place where the
bacteria multiply fast they needs they
need a host like that so anyway when
people ingest this contaminated water
they come down with cholera from which
you die in hours to days and Don Snow
who really was looking for a place where
he could unfortunate circumstances as
they were have a very concentrated
outbreak of cholera where he could study
the origins of the outbreak was
interested in helping the people but
also interested immediately in
collecting information about break so he
would have come over here at this
neighborhood and started canvassing all
the people around here to see who was
dying and who needed help but what they
had done to possibly ingest water from
the various water supplies in the area
and right here at a location right near
this red curve stone was a source of
what was apparently some very clean
pasting sweet facing actually water for
drinking right here is called the Broad
Street pump and it turned out as he
started canvassing your neighborhood
that he realized that most of the people
who had fallen ill and who were
continuing to fall ill had drunk water
from this particular column so there
were other water pumps in the
neighborhood and one of the things that
we'll see later is that in the end when
he put it all his data together and he
made a map he had to show that this pump
by walking was the closest to almost all
of the people who eventually died 600
something people who died in the
epidemic so even though there are other
pumps that are geographically
potentially nearer to those people this
one
tasted good and was close to the people
who died by walking so in epidemiology
today it's known that one way to really
make your case is to have exceptions to
the rule so people who should have died
we didn't die and then people who did
die for no apparent reason and so John
Snow and his work actually found both of
those kinds of exceptions and so one
case is what people sometimes refer to
as the people who were saved by the beer
and so those were the brewery workers
who worked a few blocks from here and
drank mostly beer and so had a clean
supply of things to drink and the other
case was the workhouse that was
here these were the most indigent
potentially people in the poorest the
Falcon so why did they live they
systematically survived this epidemic
and part of the reason the main and most
important reason is that the workhouse
had a well had its own source of clean
drinking water so there are the
exceptions of people who should have
died and didn't died and then what
happened was he also found out about a
family who would bring water to a member
of that family who had moved far a
couple miles outside of this
neighborhood and they brought her some
water and elderly aunt and she and her
niece drank it and those people both
died so to us looking at modern
epidemiological methods Jon Snow had
plenty of evidence to say that this
water from this well contained the
contaminant that caused it but it still
took actually many years until the
locals believed
and another thing that we should mention
is that Jon Snow did not collect all
this data himself if you look around the
street here you'll see that the very
busy neighborhood with lots and lots of
people and I think it was even busier in
1854 but it was a small contained
community and there were people for
example like the curate Henry Whitehead
who was a local who kind of knew
everybody and so Jon Snow worked with
Whitehead and with other people in the
area to really canvass the information
and collect the kind of sociological
demographic information that he needed
to know who lived where when they died
where they likely got their water who
they talked to who they came in contact
with all kinds of other details about
their personal lives and so that kind of
human data collection when this tightly
knit community was also really
[Music]